they'll spawn we're off
probably it to be quarry how many
elements could it contain so we take it
home
Oh terbium just like you opium is often
used in television screens and various
types of displays and where it comes in
is it gives green and yellow colors
which in contrast to the red and blue
which you opium gives you gives you the
full selection that you need to give
color images so it's a big groover it to
be mine what a great place the snows
falling the ASM is designated it to be
mine a historical landmark for the
discovery of four periodic elements
yttrium ytterbium erbium and terbium
terbium was eventually discovered or
eventually isolated by the chemist ma
sander in 1843 it was isolated from an
earth called atria which was originated
in this quarry where we are right now in
Italy in Sweden terbium is a really
unusual element it's a metal moderate
abundance it's called a rare earth
element which is really quite ironic
because it's not as rare as its name
would suggest the abundance is something
like 20 to 30 times that of silver so I
don't think it's really rare
doesn't really have much biological
activity but we do find terbium within
the bones in the human body and in
animals but also within the kidneys so
you do find small concentrations but it
doesn't really have a perceived
biological activity terbium is also used
in certain magnetic devices and when you
include it in certain alloys it forms
magnetic devices which increase or
decrease in size depending on the
strength or the type of magnetic field
which they're placed into which has
various technological applications so
terbium alloys are really quite
interesting because they have what's
called magnetostrictive behavior so what
that means is that the size of the
crystal or the size of the structure of
the alloy itself gets either larger or
smaller when it's exposed to a large or
strong magnetic field so there's much
research going into the use of these
terbium alloys for small motors and
small switches perhaps and also to use
as strain gauges and other types of
really quite elaborate instruments so
these very well provide us a lot of new
research in the areas of nanoscience and
nanoengineering
il chemistry so if you want to stain
cells and determine whether certain
types are present then you can use it
for that too so in terms of day to day
life where do we find terbium well we
find it in unusual devices like
energy-saving light bulbs because it
stimulates or it increases the yield of
light in the mercury discharge that we
use to run fluorescent strips so we find
it around us in shops and houses in
factories street lighting everywhere but
what I think is really quite nice and
important application of terbium is the
fact that it's used to make
phosphorescent materials so these are
materials which generate light or allow
us to develop pictures if we irradiated
X ray and in fact terbium is used to
make very very high light yielding
phosphors for use in screens and
visualization screens for x-rays so what
this means is that if I go into the
hospital for a diagnostic x-ray I no
longer have to be exposed to long
periods of x-rays because the the
terbium screen allows the generation of
the pictures
a much much lower dose of x-ray so it's
really really quite significant advance
it's really quite nice chemistry as well